(mouse clicking)
(tinkly music)
(upbeat music)
- Good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Tina Sacks.
I'm and Assistant Professor in the
School of Social Welfare,
and a member of the
Hitchcock Professorship Committee.
We're pleased, along with
the Graduate Council,
to present Deborah Tannen,
this spring's speaker
in the Charles M. and Martha
Hitchcock Lecture Series.
As a condition of this request,
we are obligated and happy to tell you
how the endowment came to UC Berkeley.
It's a story that
exemplifies the many ways
this campus is linked to
the history of California,
and the Bay area.
Dr. Charles Hitchcock, a
physician for the Army,
came to San Francisco
during the Gold Rush,
where he opened a
thriving private practice.
In 1885, Charles established
a professorship here
at Berkeley, as an
expression of his long-held
interest in education.
His daughter, Lillie Hitchcock Coit,
still treasured in San Francisco for her
colorful personality, as
well as her generosity,
greatly expanded her
father's original gift
to establish a professorship
at UC Berkeley.
Making it possible for us to
present a series of lectures.
The Hitchcock Fund has become one of the
most cherished endowments of
the University of California.
Recognizing the highest
distinction of scholarly
thought and achievement.
Thank you, Lillie and Charles.
And now, a few words about Deborah Tannen.
Deborah Tannen's research
examines the discourse
of everyday conversation,
including cross-cultural
and gender differences
in ways of speaking, and the
discourse of social media.
A prolific scholar, Tannen has written
critically-praised books for both
scholarly and general audiences.
Her books include, the number one,
four-year New York Times Bestseller,
You Just Don't Understand:
Women and Men in Conversation,
Talking From Nine to Five:
Women and Men at Work,
You're Wearing That?: Mothers
and Daughters in Conversation,
and You're the Only One I Can Tell:
Inside the Language of
Women's Friendships.
Her scholarly books include,
Gender and Discourse,
Conversational Style, and Talking Voices:
Repetition, Dialogue, and Imagery
in Conversational Discourse.
Deborah Tannen earned her
BA in English Literature
from Harper College.
Her MA in English Literature
from Wayne State University.
And her MA and PhD in Linguistics
right here at UC Berkeley.
She is the recipient of
five honorary Doctorates.
Since 1979, she has been on the faculty
of Georgetown University's
Department of Linguistics,
and since 1991, has held the
rank of University Professor.
She has been the McGraw
Distinguished Lecturer
at Princeton University,
spent a term in residence
at the Institute for
Advanced Study at Princeton,
and has twice been a Fellow at the
Center for Advanced Study at the
Behavioral Sciences at Stanford.
She is also a member of the Board of the
PEN/Faulkner Foundation.
Today's lecture, in today's lecture,
Tannen will draw on her
interviews with 80 women,
ranging in age from nine to 97.
And on her years of research,
examining how ways of
talking effect relationships.
To explore the role of talk among friends,
with particular focus
on women's friendships.
How they compare to men's,
and the consequences of such differences.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. Deborah Tannen
back to Berkeley.
(audience applauding)
- Wow, thank you!
And I didn't even say anything yet.
Thanks so much.
What a thrill, to be
back at Berkeley where,
as you heard, I got my PhD in 1979,
and everything that I'm gonna
be saying today, started.
Tomorrow I'm gonna be
introduced by Robin Lakoff,
who was the reason that
I came to Berkeley.
And just for those of you
who won't be here tomorrow,
I just wanna say how much I owe to her.
It was attending a course that she taught
at the University of Michigan,
summer of 1973 that I got the idea,
this is what I have to do
for the rest of my life.
And I'm nearer to the
rest of my life right now.
Thank you so much for coming.
As you heard, I'm going
to be talking about
the language of women's friendships.
Much of what I say
though, will also be true
of friendships among women and men,
in particular, women and gay men,
friendships between men.
There are things about
friendships that will
apply across the board.
But there also are patterns that tend to
distinguish friendships among women
and friendships among men.
And tend to is very important.
Everything I say about gender,
I always make a point of saying some,
many, tendency, and it often
gets translated as all.
Or, norms.
We're not talking about norms,
we're not talking about 100%,
but we're talking about tendencies.
As you heard, I interviewed a large number
of girls and women.
Nine to 97.
I heard comments like,
my friendships with women
are as essential as air.
My women friends are the most
sustaining thing in my life.
I heard many, many comments like that.
And you heard that I wrote a book about
mothers and daughters.
You were in that.
I comment in that book, that love between
mothers and daughters can be as intense,
as complicated, as
passionate as romantic love.
And I found in doing this research,
that the same also could be
said about some friendships.
But I did also hear comments like,
I find friendships with women difficult
terrain to navigate.
And I'm gonna try to say
something about both sides
of those friendships.
A woman that I talked to said,
in telling me how much she would do
for her friend.
She said, if a friend
called at three o'clock
in the morning, and said I need bail,
I'd say, can I come in my nightie?
I'll be right there.
I heard a story that a woman told me about
when she was in 3rd grade.
Her friends had heard, picked up,
that she was going through something
very difficult and challenging,
and the word was out.
And how her friends, this is 3rd grade,
just formed a phalanx
around her, to protect her.
So they didn't ask what was going on,
they didn't ask details out of respect
for her privacy, but if they sensed that
another girl was about to ask her,
they would sort of close in around her,
and prevent that friend, that girl,
from getting close to her.
And so, it was just so moving to hear
how early that kind of loyalty
to friends could start.
I heard about friends who
flew across the country
when a friend had a loss, or an illness.
Stayed for weeks, even months, to help.
Friends who called every day for a year,
when her friend lost her husband.
And friends who call every
day for no particular reason.
Just to stay in touch.
To know what's happening.
And being in touch, and
knowing what's happening
in each other's lives is often,
not only what is
treasured, but also what is
required of friendship.
And in a way, that was
the most significant
thing that I heard about over and over.
A friend is someone
who's available to talk
when you need to.
A woman told me a situation, very sad,
that's not uncommon, how
terrible she was feeling
because she had lost a very close friend,
life-long friend who had passed away.
And she said, you know, the worst thing
is that I can't call her up and tell her
how terrible I feel about her dying.
Because that was the person she would call
when she went through something like that.
Comparing women's friendships to men's.
This is a conversation
that a woman told me
she had with her son, that I think
captures some of that.
So this is a son, who had
recently graduated from college,
was living across the country.
And she was asking, talking on the phone,
asking him about a friend
that she knew very well.
And the conversation
went something like this.
Have you talked to Mike lately?
And he said, yep, talked to him yesterday.
How's he doing?
I don't know.
(audience laughing)
But you just talked
to him, didn't he say?
Nope.
Well, how's his job?
I don't know.
How's his girlfriend?
Don't know.
Well, what did you talk about?
Football.
Did you only talk about football?
No, soccer too.
That would be fairly
unusual among women friends.
And there was a man in the audience,
and when I talked about this,
who approached me after.
And he said, you know, the same thing,
it's still true.
He said he and his wife
are very good friends
with another couple.
The wives get together,
the guys get together.
And one evening, his wife said to him,
isn't that terrible that
they're getting divorced?
And he had no idea.
He said they had played tennis
every week for months, years.
But, he said, the topic of
his marriage never came up.
And that would be surprising
among women friends.
Good women friends.
I teach at Georgetown
University, I teach a class
called Cross-Cultural
Communication, for undergrads.
And part of the course
requirement is that everybody,
every week, describes some interaction
that they've been part of.
They write about it, and they analyze it
in terms of what we have
been doing in class.
Methods, theories we've been discussing.
And so I wanna read you
a part of a field note.
I call it field notes,
that a student wrote.
This is gonna be my first sip of water,
and the first of many, I'm sure.
She wrote, "Saturday night after a party,
"a group of us went to
Matt's house to hang out
"before we went home to bed.
"I, and the other girls proceeded
to sit down on the couch.
"and we began talking about the night.
"What we thought was fun,
"what we wished had happened, et cetera.
"I was in the middle of
giving my friend, Sarah,
"advice about a boy, when all of a sudden
"the coffee table was
pushed out of the way,
"and the guys began to wrestle.
"Throwing each other on the couch,
"pushing each other off chairs.
"It was funny for me to
see my big, guys friends
"wrestling as if they were five year olds.
"But it also struck me that this is how
"we chose to relax.
"The girls began talking,
and the guys got up
"and started play fighting."
And this was something that
we had discussed in class.
That those who study kids at play,
do find that often boys will play fight.
Girls do fight, they
just don't fight for fun.
They fight when they mean it.
And the girls will spend more
time sitting and talking.
I was interested though,
she said it was funny
to see her guy friends
acting like five year olds.
But she and her girlfriends were also
But they were acting
like five year old girls.
She also, I was intrigued
that she made the point
that she was giving her
friends advice about a boy,
advice about troubles.
It is not at all unusual for conversations
among women, to talk about some kind
of problems that they're having.
And there was a woman,
this is a woman in her 80s,
but she remembered this story,
that captured how this can function.
It was a conversation.
The scenario was, she was quite young,
she was home with her toddler little boy.
Her neighbor had a
little boy, similar age.
And she said, one day she
got a call from her neighbor.
And she was kind of upset
because her little boy
had dropped a jar of mayonnaise
on the kitchen floor,
spread the mayonnaise all over the floor,
and added eggs to it, because
he was gonna make a cake.
(audience laughing)
What she said was, she just left the mess,
and came over, and we just
drank coffee and commiserated.
And I love that word commiserated,
because this is one of
the functions, often,
that talking about troubles can have.
It didn't help clean up the mess,
didn't change her neighbor's situation,
and yet, I'm sure they
did both feel much better
to realize that they were
both in the same boat.
And here was somebody
who had a child that was
similar age, and was going
through something similar.
There's a term that we sometimes use,
not exactly a technical term,
but those of us who study conversation
call it, troubles talk.
And this is a particular
kind of talk that again,
is more common often among
women friends than men.
And it seems quite universal.
I have a student from Kazakhstan,
and she was home one summer,
and interviewed women in
Kazakhstan about their friendships.
And one of the women that
she interviewed there,
made this comment.
She said, "When you have talked to someone
"about something that's bothering you,
"it's lighter on the soul.
"The days seem sunnier,
and troubles step back,
"and start seeming smaller."
And I thought that was such
a lovely way to put it.
I also though, wanna go back to something
that I said about
troubles talk in the book,
You Just Don't Understand, that I would
put a little differently now.
I don't think what I said
then was exactly right.
One of the scenarios that
I wrote about in that book,
that got a lot of attention,
I guess it rang a lot of bells,
was a scenario where a
woman might tell a man
about a problem that she's having,
and he tells her how to fix the problem.
And she's frustrated, because
what I said at the time was,
she didn't want a solution,
she wanted to talk about it.
And he's frustrated, 'cause he's thinking,
why do you wanna talk
about it if you don't
wanna do anything about it?
And they're both frustrated
because they're trying
to be good people, and
they're being told that
they're not being good people.
So that's what I commented on at the time.
I would say something different now.
I don't think it would be correct to say
she doesn't want a solution.
Remember those girls on the couch.
She said, I was giving my friend Sarah,
advice about a boy.
It's not that we don't give advice.
But I think maybe she
didn't want a solution
right off the bat.
So, if you tell about
a problem to a friend,
a good friend, you might
expect something like,
gee, why do you think he said that?
And then, what did you say?
And then, how did he respond to that?
And then, what do you think you might do?
And what do you think would
happen if you did that?
And you ask a series of questions.
And partly this 'cause
you need the information
to know what advice to give.
But I think there's another level, too.
In much of what I write, I talk about
the two levels of meaning in conversation.
One is the message level,
and the other is the meta-message level.
So the message would be
the meaning of the words,
and in case you're interested,
this all comes from the
anthropologist Gregory Bateson.
But he applied it somewhat differently.
I apply it to conversation.
The message is the meaning of the words,
but the meta-message is what
it says about the relationship,
that you say these words
in this way, at this time.
So, perhaps the problem is the message,
but being willing to talk about it.
To ask the questions, to
listen to the answers.
To take that time to be
engaged about something
that's bothering you.
This sends a meta-message of caring.
And I suspect that part
of the frustration,
is a woman tells a man about a problem,
and he gives her the solution,
isn't that she didn't want a solution,
she just didn't want it right off the bat.
And giving the solution
shuts down the conversation.
Whereas starting that
conversation was part of
her motivation in bringing it up.
I sometimes say as an aside,
shutting down the conversation
may actually be a secondary gain for him.
'Cause if he isn't used to
having conversations like that,
he might not actually
appreciate having to go,
get into all those details.
But being interested in
it, has that meta-message
that I think is valued.
There's another kind of
conversation that is very
common among women, and
that is very valued.
And that is exchanging secrets.
I collect pictures from
all over the world,
of two little girls.
And one is whispering in the other's ear.
And I've been fascinated by having
encountered pictures like that from such
disparate cultures across the world.
I have encountered them about boys,
but much, much more rarely.
In fact, I had said,
'cause it was the case,
that I had never encountered
such pictures among boys,
and somebody who was in
the audience sent me one.
So I can't say I've never seen one.
But it isn't as common.
And this is something that
I heard about over and over.
So, as one woman put it, she said,
a close friend knows things about me
that nobody else does.
She said, if someone is a true friend,
I tell her everything I
think, and everything I feel.
A woman that I was
interviewing was telling me
about various friendships,
and she said at one point
about one friends, she's
not that close a friend.
I wouldn't tell her
about my kids' problems.
And then, later in the conversation,
she said about another friend,
she's not that close a friend.
I wouldn't tell her what I had for dinner.
(audience laughing)
Now this might seem odd.
You could think why you would only tell
about family troubles to a
friend that's a good friend,
but why you wouldn't tell her what you're
having for dinner.
When you think about it,
there's that end of day
conversation with people
you're really close to.
Could be a family member,
could be a romantic partner,
could be a friend.
And you say what you
did, and where you went,
and what that made you think,
and what that made you feel.
And where you went to
dinner, and what you ordered.
Or maybe what you prepared for dinner
while you were at home.
So again, it's an aspect
of detail of your life,
the caring about which, sends
a meta-message of closeness.
Again, writing about
mothers and daughters,
I encountered the daughter
who said about her mother,
who else can I tell I got a
good deal on toilet paper?
(audience laughing)
Somebody who cares about
that level of detail
in your life, is something precious.
A meta-message of caring.
When people told me that
they were hurt by friends,
and that is always something
that I did ask about.
One reason that I often heard
as a reason for being hurt,
was not being included,
or not being invited.
And this is more common
among women than among men.
Again, I refer to people
who study kids at play.
Not my research, but
the patterns are clear
from those who have studied kids at play.
That when boys don't like a boy,
they let him play, but
they treat him badly.
When girls don't like a girl,
they lock her out.
And when you think about the fact that
friends are telling each other secrets,
your friends are people
that know things about you
that others don't, that could be something
behind the reason why you
can't have girls there
who you don't wanna be friends with,
because they can't hear your secrets.
So that may be something going on there.
So you've probably heard of FOMO, F-O-M-O,
which is fear of missing out.
That's the reason that we check our email,
or our phones, or our
Instagram, constantly checking,
because you don't wanna miss out.
There may be something happening,
and if you don't check it
in time, you'll miss out.
I devised two more acronyms.
FOBLO, F-O-B-L-O.
Fear of being left out.
And that's worse than FOMO.
With FOMO, you miss the party 'cause you
didn't check your phone in time.
With FOBLO, you missed the party
because you weren't invited.
And that's worse.
That actually can be more hurtful.
And I'll have more to
say about that tomorrow,
because this is one of
the risks of social media.
That you're always seeing
everybody doing things
when you're not there.
So, that feeling of being
left out can be aggravated.
But again, it comes out
of the real experience
of having been left out.
And FOGKO, F-O-G-K-O, fear
of getting kicked out.
Groups of girls will
often turn on one girl
and kick her out.
I heard stories like that, especially from
middle school and high school.
But I did also hear some
stories from adult groups.
And again, my colleagues
who study kids at play
have encountered this in real time.
I have a colleague, Amy Sheldon.
And she has studied preschoolers.
And she actually recorded conversation
among these little preschoolers.
A couple of them were playing.
A bunch of them were playing house.
And one girl came over to join
them that they didn't like.
They didn't want her to join.
Well you know, they tell
you in many of these
nursery schools, you
can't say you can't play.
They know that.
So they told her she could play.
And the one who was assigning roles said,
you can be the baby brother,
but you aren't born yet.
(audience laughing)
She gave her a non-speaking part.
So, very creative at
that, so young in age.
Of kind of locking out
those that you don't like.
I heard so many stories
from women, now adults,
who still feel guilty
about having been part
of groups in middle school or high school
that locked somebody
out, kicked somebody out.
And one really stuck in my mind.
This is woman now, she's
a real estate salesperson,
and very successful.
She's in her 40s.
She still feels guilty because
when she was in high school,
the group of friends,
and they had been friends
since middle school,
decided to eject a girl
who had been in their
group in middle school.
And she's the one who
I was talking to said,
she had been really close to that girl.
And she felt terrible
that she was kicked out.
And she said about her,
she was really cute,
and really good at sports.
And this really made me stop and think,
because among boy's
groups, someone who was
physically attractive and
really good at sports,
their status in the group goes up.
So wouldn't that be a reason
to keep her in the group,
rather than a reason to
eject her from the group?
When girls eject a girl, turn on a girl,
once you punish a girl,
they will say things like she
really thinks she's something.
She's stuck up.
She's snobby.
I heard so many stories like this.
One of the beautiful,
wonderful things about
girls and women's friendships,
is a valuing of sameness.
I tell you about a
problem, and you might say,
oh I know how you feel,
I'd feel the say way.
I tell you I feel bad
about something I did.
You say, oh I know, I woulda
done exactly the same thing.
It's this feeling of
sameness which makes you
feel less alone in the world.
But that expectation of
sameness can be a requirement.
And if you're not the
same, especially if you
seem somewhat better,
or seem to think you're
somewhat better, then
girls can be very critical.
And that is what one of the women said,
who told me that, she said in her words,
"I find friendships with women difficult
terrain to navigate."
That's what she said in
explanation, partial explanation.
She said, if you have an
opinion that's different,
or you've chosen a different path,
my women friends will often
take that as criticism
or a valued judgment.
So the expectation of being the same
can be a downside.
Often, this is a point I
make repeatedly in the book.
The wonderful things and
the challenging things
are often two sides of the same coin.
And I think that is the case with this
valuing of sameness.
And I think this valuing
of being the same,
and tendency to be critical
of women who seem better,
is one of the things that
presents a double bind
for women in positions of authority.
This is not about women's
friendships so much,
although it does come up in friendships,
but something that I wrote
about at great length
in essays and other subjects
about women in the workplace.
And certainly wrote some op-eds
about Hillary Clinton
in the last campaign.
That some od the criticism,
I just don't like her,
I think came from this
feeling of discomfort
with a woman who seems not
to be self-deprecating,
not to be putting herself down,
but seems to be comfortable with being
in a position of authority.
That's a side points.
That's a footnote to my talk here.
But there were many examples
that I encountered of that.
I just recently saw a
play in New York called,
Coming From Away.
Did any of you see that?
Yeah, it's based on a real situation,
and it's a musical.
There's a song in that play,
and it's based on a real character.
The woman who was the first pilot,
first female pilot at American Airlines.
And she sings this song about her life.
And there's this line in
the song where she says,
when she showed up as
the first Captain pilot,
in the cockpit of a plane,
the men were very unhappy,
they felt a girl doesn't
belong in the cockpit.
And she says, the stewardesses
weren't my friend either.
They said, do you think
you're better than us?
So that's that pattern that I encountered.
Telling this story, again, people come up
from the audience and tell
me similar experiences.
Just recently, was told by a woman,
that her granddaughter in 2nd grade,
was really unhappy because
her three close friends
told her they couldn't
be her friend anymore
because she had won the spelling bee.
Now, the happy ending
is at least two of them
changed their minds.
They came around.
Decided that was not a good
reason to end the friendship.
I'm talking about the place
of secrets in friendships.
And the precious thing of feeling that
somebody knows what's going on,
and you can tell them what's
going on in your life.
One woman put it this way, and I really
like the way she put it.
I thought this was very sweet.
She said, when she tells a
friend something personal
it's like saying, here's
this little piece of me.
That means I like you.
I thought that was very sweet.
But when you think about it,
now she has a piece of you.
What's she gonna do with it?
And that is one of the
liabilities that I heard
quite a lot of stories
about among women friends.
So, she might repeat it inadvertently,
not realizing it was
supposed to be a secret,
or just letting it slip
out without meaning to.
She might, and this I heard
again from high school students,
let it out on purpose
because she got mad at you.
And there's another reason
that girls and women
are very tempted to let other people know
that they know your secrets.
And this is again, related to something
that I wrote about in You
Just Don't Understand.
It was said about that book,
and I did say this in the book,
relating to other people's research,
that girls tend to be
cooperative in situations
where boys might be more competitive.
I wouldn't put it that way anymore,
because I think both girls and boys,
women and men, we are all competitive
and we're all cooperative,
but maybe in different ways.
And one of the ways that girls and women
can be very competitive,
is who knows what,
and who knows first.
So, if you're in a group of friends,
the person who knows
something important first,
feels like she's raised in
the hierarchy of friends.
And sisters, when I wrote
a book about sisters,
several, more than one told me,
if they have really important news
they have to have a conference call.
Because if they call one first,
the others are gonna be offended.
And sometimes now, we do
that with close friends,
with group emails.
So you're telling
everybody at the same time.
And the reason for that, I think, again,
especially among girls and women,
closeness is like the pot of gold
at the end of the relationship rainbow.
And knowing secrets, knowing
what's going on in your life
if evidence of that closeness.
And so there's a real
temptation to let people know
how close you are, by letting
them know that you know this.
A woman told me that her
mother had warned her
from the time she was pretty young,
be very careful about
sharing personal information
with women who get their
hair done every week,
or women who play Bridge regularly.
And the reason her mother said was,
when they run out of
things about themselves
to talk about, they will
move on to talking about you.
And I think that's interesting,
not only from the perspective
of repeating secrets,
but also it's just showing the assumption
that what they wanna talk about is people,
and personal relationships.
And that's why you need fodder
for those conversations.
Another thing that I often heard about
when people were hurt, was not
having been told something.
A woman told me about a very close friend,
they had traveled together,
she had been helping her
friend with something or other,
and then her friend came
to her and announced
that she had been having an affair
and was getting a divorce.
And the woman I interviewed said,
and she wanted me to
be on board with that.
But I felt like she had lied to me.
Because I had been telling her what was
going on in my life, and she had hidden
such an important thing from me.
So she experienced it almost as a lie.
So the requirement to
let your friends know
what is going on in your
life is another thing
that is both a gift, but is
also, can become limiting.
I have heard some of the women who told me
they prefer friendships with men.
That was one of the reasons they gave me.
They said they felt that they could
trust men not to tell their secrets.
And I don't think its that men are
inherently more trustworthy than women,
but I think it's because they
have nothing to gain by it.
Whereas we women have a lot
to gain by letting others
know that they know your secrets,
and therefore, evidence
that you are close to them.
I wanna move to another element
that is more common among
women's friendships than men.
Again, there's always
cultural differences in this.
And I know of many
instances where it doesn't
fit this gender pattern,
but I'm gonna read you
these two contrasting field notes,
written by students in my class,
describing problems with their roommates.
And in both cases, it has to do with,
well you'll hear it, but
it's a similar challenge
in dealing with roommates.
And I want to read first,
how this young woman
described this problem,
and how she solved it.
"On a couple of different
occasions last week
"I heard my roommates
mention they wanted to
"have a party of Thursday.
"I didn't think much of it
until Thursday afternoon
"when I realized I would be up all night
"writing a paper that
was due Friday morning.
"I didn't wanna be the annoying roommate
"that wouldn't allow a party.
"But at the same time, I
didn't want distractions
"while I was trying to finish
a paper under a deadline.
"So as I was walking back from class
"with one of my roommates, I asked, so,
"what are you guys doing tonight?
"She responded, I'm not sure.
"We're thinking of having a
party, what are you up to?
"I told her I had a big
paper due on Friday.
"She responded, Oh, in
that case we definitely
"won't have a party.
"I told her it would be fine with me.
"But she restated that they
would not have a party,
"and that time I did not resist."
I have at times described this
as a kind of indirectness.
She knew her roommates
were having a party,
but she didn't state that.
She started kind of vague.
What are you guys thinking?
She needed to tell them
not to have the party,
but she didn't say it outright.
She let them know what the reason was
that she'd rather them not have a party,
and let her friend decide
on her own not to have it.
And I especially love that first one,
they said they wouldn't have a party,
and I say, no, no, it's fine with me.
Because again, she doesn't want to be
that annoying roommate,
but she trusts her friend
to come to the right decision.
So now I want to contrast
that with the way
a young man described
how his apartment mate
solved a similar problem.
This is what he wrote.
"I could not help but
overhear a brief exchange
"between my apartment mates this week.
"I was doing something or other in my room
"with the door open.
"One of my apartment mates was in his room
"with the door closed, cramming for his
"Organic Chemistry test the next day.
"My other two apartment
mates were watching
"the World Series in the common room,
"passionately yelling at every player.
"This went on for awhile,
until the one studying
"opened the door and yelled,
guys can you keep it down?
"I'm studying here.
"The response was no.
"The one studying followed
with a quick, go to hell."
The conversation concluded with a remark
from the common room which
I cannot say in public,
but it starts with the letter f.
And they said f you.
They actually said it.
And the student continues.
"And with that, the problem was solved."
(audience laughing)
"They lowered the volume on the television
"and mellowed out considerably.
"No one was mad, just a typical way of
"problem solving in Henley 60."
The contrast is pretty striking.
If you try to imagine a group of women
having a conversation like that,
it's a little hard to imagine.
Try to imagine the guys
having a conversation
like the one the girls had.
It's a little hard to imagine.
One of the things I find very
intriguing here though is,
the boys were also indirect.
If indirectness is not saying
what you mean outright,
they didn't say what they meant outright.
They said no, they said go to hell,
but they were going to accommodate.
So it was also indirect.
But it's a different kind of indirectness.
It's a mock aggression.
And that is very common
among boys and men.
A kind of teasing.
The kind of showing
affection with his punching.
It's a kind of mock aggression that has
the same meta-message of
friendliness and closeness.
I had an occasion to
observe a very similar
kind of negotiation among women
at a very professional situation.
This was a meeting that
was, a conference that
was being organized by someone,
it was for professional women,
and I was gonna be one
of the plenary speakers.
And the women organizing
it told me when I arrived,
that another one of the plenary speakers,
who was a mutual friend of
ours was not going to come.
And she said to me, this
is what she said to me.
She said, Judy isn't
going to be making it.
She called me this morning, and she said,
I'm really sick.
I know I'm coming down with something,
I feel horrible.
But if you really need
me, I'll come and talk.
And the organizer said to me.
I told her I need you to stay home
and take care of yourself.
I said, I love that.
Can I use it in my talk?
And she said, yes, yes you can, of course.
It was such great, perfect,
direct communication.
(audience)
And I think this is so revealing.
Why did she think it was direct?
Judy said I'll come if you need me to.
There was no way on
Earth she was gonna go.
She knew that the
organizer wasn't gonna say,
I don't care if you're
sick, get out of bed
and come here and talk.
It was direct because it was clear.
She knew exactly what was meant,
and she did her part in
the conversational routine.
And this is the beauty of indirectness.
It is something that Robin Lakoff,
who I mentioned at the beginning,
wrote about way back, and I heard about
in that first course that I took with her,
back in 1973.
We, especially Americans, can sometime be
a little bit critical of
indirect communication.
I'm often asked, wouldn't
this be a better world
if we just all said what we meant?
To which I often say, well we do,
but we use our own conversational style.
And if someone's style is different,
then they don't know how
we mean what we said.
But, Robin has written,
and I think it's so true,
that there's a great satisfaction in that
kind of indirect communication.
So Judy, the one who wasn't able to speak,
didn't have to feel she's
letting her friend down.
Her friend let her off the hook.
And the organizer didn't have to feel
she was presented with a fait accompli.
She's the one who made that decision.
I can't resist telling you though,
that I also encountered
a very direct observation
where it didn't work with someone who
didn't share that style.
I was in the office of
a faculty colleague.
She answered the phone while I was there,
so I just heard her side
of the conversation.
And it was something like, I don't see how
I possibly could.
I am so overwhelmed this term.
I'm on the rank and tenure committee,
I knew it would be a lot of work.
But it's more work than I could imagine.
Teaching an overload course.
Four of my dissertation students
are defending this term.
I don't see how I could possibly do it.
But if you can't find anybody else.
(audience laughing)
And when she hung up the phone,
she looked at me with this true look
of astonishment on her face.
And she said, I can't believe it.
I told him I couldn't do it,
and he put me on the committee anyway.
(audience laughing)
So this is this direct communication.
She felt she had told him that.
And he took what she said literally,
because he wasn't, I'm guessing,
he wasn't used to that
kind of ritual offer.
That is self-evident you're
not supposed to accept.
Indirectness like that
can be confusing among
same sex friends.
It's an element of what I've described
as conversational style.
Many of the different things I've written.
And I have several
examples that I encounter.
The people told me,
frustration with friends,
even close friends, who
had difference sense
of conversational style.
And sometimes different
sense of indirectness.
One was a woman who had visited.
Okay she and another friend,
they had gone to college together,
lived in the same city.
A friend, a guy visited
who knew them both,
and he was visiting this one.
And he said he'd really
like to see the other one.
So she said fine, I'll call her up and see
if she wants to see us, if she's free.
She called up the third, the other friend,
said so-and-so is in town.
He'd like to see you.
Do you want to see him?
She said, yeah sure, bring him over.
She did bring him over.
The next day, she called,
and she was livid.
Why did you do that?
Why did you bring him over?
I hate him.
You know I hate him.
And she said, but you said
you wanted us to come over.
Yeah, but you should have
known by the way I said it
that I didn't mean it.
Which seems ridiculous to those of us
who don't use that kind of indirectness,
but it's self-evident, I
think would be self-evident
to someone who shared that style.
I don't know if any of you noticed this,
but I had an op-ed in the New York Times
just a few weeks ago.
And in it I tell this anecdote.
And I was so embarrassed that I myself
missed the possibility of indirectness.
See, I've written about
this since the 1970s,
and I still missed it.
I had a friend visiting.
I won't tell you the
whole story behind it,
but the bottom line was, she was helping
to serve, and to clean up, and to act,
in my view, act like
a host in my own home,
and I kept telling her not to.
And she kept doing it anyway.
And I would tell her not to,
and she would still do it.
At one point, she made
it into the kitchen.
I physically grabbed
her and yanked her back,
and pushed her down in the chair.
And I tried to do it in a way that seemed
good-natured, but I was really rattled.
I really didn't like it.
Now, she's a good friend.
I wasn't gonna like,
stop being her friend,
but I was gonna think twice
about having her over again.
(audience laughing)
And would normally have just let it go,
but because I was writing
this book about friends,
I felt, it's research, I
need to know her perspective.
I need to know why she kept doing it
when I told her not to.
So I talked to her about it.
And when I described it,
a look of astonishment
went across her face.
It had never occurred
to her that I meant it.
And she told me, in the
op-ed I wrote about it
as family styles, or mother styles.
She had just been at her parent's house.
They're older.
She was helping.
Every stage she was helping.
Her mother kept telling her not to,
she kept doing it anyway.
And at the end of the evening,
her mother said thank you.
And she even said at one point,
you never listen to me.
And I am so glad you don't.
There was no question in her mind,
that people tell you they
don't want you to help,
but they really want you to.
And it had never occurred
to me that she didn't
think I meant it.
And it's so funny, 'cause
I've written about this.
And that's the thing about
conversational style.
What seems right to us
just seems self-evident.
So this has been great.
She says she's very relieved now,
to know she doesn't
have to do all the work
at everybody's house.
If they tell her not to the third time,
she can actually listen, and not do it.
And I can now meta-communicate, and say,
by the way, I really do mean this,
I'm not just saying it.
But I encountered many other examples
of conversational style differences.
Where a friend was offended by something
that another friend
said, or was put off by
something that was really
just a style difference.
Two women, very close friends,
they're walking around the lake.
One is telling the other about something
that she really feels strongly about.
And the one she's telling
to is really listening.
And also when she sees
something that's really pretty,
that's really interesting
like, looks at those ducks
going along the lake, and there's little
ducklings behind her.
Or, oh look at that flower,
isn't that beautiful?
If you didn't call attention to it,
you're walking, and it would be gone.
Your friend would miss it.
At one point, the friend who
was telling about the problem,
she stopped dead in her tracks,
and she turned to her friend and she said,
you haven't listened to a word I've said.
And the one who told me the anecdote
was that friend who felt
so unfairly criticized.
Of course she was listening.
This is a conversational style difference.
And I'm curious how many people here think
if you're listening to something,
you can't talk.
You can't say look at that,
or throw in a comment.
And how many of you feel of course,
that's perfectly fine.
It's kind of like you're having dinner
and you want the salt, and
someone's telling a story.
You don't have to go without salt
'til they finish their story.
You might say, excuse me, pass the salt.
And that's not an interruption.
Another friend, I encountered an example
of another friend with a
conversational difference.
Anybody here from South Carolina?
This friend of mine is
from South Carolina.
If you have not yet guessed,
I grew up in Brooklyn, New York.
From my hands, or my accent.
So, pretty good friends.
So we're talking about something,
and I was telling her about,
we were talking about some
guy that we both knew,
not particularly well.
And I asked her what she thought of him.
And she said, I don't really know him.
And I said, I think he's a jerk.
And she said, that's what I just said.
(audience laughing)
And I said, huh?
But she knows I study this sort of thing,
so she explained it to me.
She said, in South Carolina,
you cannot say somebody's a jerk.
So you have to proceed on the assumption
that if you knew him long enough,
you would find something to like.
So, I don't really know
him means I haven't
found anything to like about him.
(audience laughing)
You know, I followed her argument,
but I didn't quite believe it, 'cause it
seemed so farfetched.
Luckily, not very long
after, I was at some
sort of a gathering, and I met someone
who said he was from South Carolina.
So I thought I'll test this.
I said, what would it
mean if you asked someone
what they thought of someone,
and she said, I don't really know him.
He said, that means he's
a no-good, no-count.
(audience laughing)
So, conversational style differences.
And you can imagine, I can imagine
how a person who used
that style would react
to someone like me who
says I think he's a jerk.
You can't say that.
They must think I'm a
jerk for talking that way.
And what I would think about someone who
expects me to know that she
didn't mean what she said,
that would seem rather unacceptable to me.
And these conversational style differences
really are very significant.
And I have a chapter of
that, and quite a lot
of examples about that.
I'll just give you one last one.
A woman who told me that she was very hurt
by a friend, because her mother
had been in the hospital.
She was terribly worried about her.
She told her friend about it.
And the friend never
asked, how's your mother?
She just assumed that's
what a friend does.
So she told the friend
that she was hurt by that.
And the friend, again, was incredulous.
She said, oh my goodness.
In my family, you don't
ask questions like that.
If you wanted to tell me about it,
you would tell me.
But it would be very
intrusive for me to ask.
And she was Vietnamese-American.
And I suspect that did have a role.
And some of these
differences are regional,
ethnic, cultural, and sometimes
just conversational style.
The very expectation
that you ask questions
as a way of showing interest,
which would be self-evident
to some people,
to others would be intrusive.
So, these conversational style differences
can be very significant.
Okay, so let me wrap up.
Obviously I've only been able to say
some of the stuff that's in the book.
But the goal really is to understand
the ways that these friendships work.
What makes them so gratifying,
but also, what make them
challenging at times.
And as I said, often the challenging
and the satisfying are two
sides of the same coin.
When I talk about it, I often focus
on some of the problem things.
'Cause I think, kind of people,
that's where they want help
with solving these problems.
A talk show I was on, it
was a radio call in show,
and somebody called in
and said, that's terrible.
You're describing awful friendships.
I would never have friendships like that.
And I said, I hope I
didn't give the impression
that I think every friendship has
these kinds of problems at every moment.
There really is a lot
about what is precious
about friendships, and
that is really what I
heard about more than anything else.
How precious those friendships can be.
And in particular, I kept being
struck by the role of talk.
And that is again, one of the things that
really does tend to distinguish
women's friendships in particular.
But talk is something that can get you
into more trouble than maybe, activities.
And sometimes I have
been told by women that
they feel there's too much talk.
A woman especially was telling me
when she went through her divorce,
she avoided her women
friends, 'cause she didn't
wanna talk about it.
She said she really valued a guy friend
who was also going through a divorce.
They just rode their bikes
for hours and didn't talk.
And so I think sometimes that can be
almost a liberation to realize you don't
always have to talk.
Just as it can be a
liberation to realize that
you can talk.
So, I'll just end by saying that,
in everything that I'm saying
about women friendships
is probably true of many
other relationships.
And also again, it's not limited to women.
It's women and men.
Certainly I could say
a lot about friendships
among women and gay men.
My own best friend is a gay man,
and I do have some things to
say about that in the book.
But, I guess overall,
I would like to leave
a sense of appreciation, and also caution
about the role of talk in
these close relationships.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
We do have time for questions?
- [Tina] Yes.
So, I would just like to
open it up for questions,
and also to thank Dr.
Tannen for her comments.
And if you have a question,
please approach the mic.
- It's intimidating, but
if you have a question,
come to the microphone.
- Yes, thank you.
- It's an open book in here, including me.
- [Woman In Blue Shirt] Hi.
I'd like to thank you.
Your book, You Just Don't Understand
helped start my marriage
off at a really good spot,
and we even say to each
other, do you want ice cream?
- I'm happy to hear that.
- And my husband says no,
and then we laugh at all that.
I'm hoping for two things from you.
I'm an East Coast transplant.
I'm from Philadelphia.
Lived there for, grew up there.
Came out to California about 30 years ago.
And I still have trouble
communicating with Californians.
(audience laughing)
- Now I have to interrupt here,
because I'm from Brooklyn,
I'm gonna interrupt.
(laughing)
My dissertation was a comparison of
New York and California
conversational styles.
- [Woman In Blue Shirt] That's
what I wanted to ask you.
Do you have a book?
You have a book on mothers
and daughters, and women.
Do you have a book on East
Coast versus West Coast?
That direct stuff you
would just talking about
at the end of your
speech is my life story.
And I've gotten in trouble so many times.
30 years out here and I can't fix it.
Do you have a book on that?
- I do.
- Or can you point me
to a book on that?
And also, the last piece of that is,
what advice do you have for someone who
obviously can't change
the way she communicates,
and yet gets in trouble
for that very thing?
- Yeah, okay.
So just let me say a little bit about,
so it was my dissertation.
It's a book.
It's an academic book, but it's pretty,
everything I write it pretty readable.
The book is called Conversational Style:
Analyzing Talk Among Friends.
And then I have the book called,
That's Not What I Meant, which is just all
the things that can differ,
including the things
that differ New York and California.
But this may be some of
what you're experiencing.
It was so shocking to me,
and I have more to say
about this tomorrow,
that I'd be accused of being rude
when in New York I was
considered overly polite.
- Thank you.
Yes.
- I had friends who literally would say
I'm not really New York Jewish,
which is what I am.
It's just in New York
it's easier being Jewish.
I must really be a wasp,
because I'm so indirect,
and so you know.
And suddenly here, I
was being called rude.
And it's things like talking
along to show enthusiasm,
and you're perceived as
indirect, as interrupting.
The length of pause between turns.
And this can vary, not just
New York and California,
but Californians and New England.
Or New England and the South.
Anytime two people are talking,
if one is conducting a
slightly shorter pause,
you get the feeling that the other person
has nothing to say, and
you wanna be a nice person
and save the conversation,
so you start speaking.
And if that person is waiting
for a slightly longer pause,
it never comes, and they feel interrupted.
So, yeah, and on, and on,
and on, things like that.
What can you do?
I'd say meta-communicate.
Talk about it.
That example I gave was my
really close friend, Tamara.
Had I left it that she
has this weird pattern
that she keeps helping
when I tell her not to,
that wouldn't been where it stayed.
But when we talked about it,
we really were able to figure it out.
And it was a gift, I
think, to the both of us.
Raised my awareness to
apply what I'd written about
in my own life.
People may not think I mean what I say.
And for her to realize that sometimes
people really mean what they say.
So, meta-communicating.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
Can you come up?
- [Woman In White Shirt]
Thanks for your speech.
I think the research you are doing is very
interesting and exciting.
And speaking of the friendship,
I recall classical and
controversial old question,
at least I think so.
And do you think there
is a simple and pure
friendship between a girl and a boy?
- So the question is, is
simple, pure friendship
possible between a girl and boy.
Is that the question?
- Yeah.
Friendship, just a friendship.
Have nothing to do with
love relationship or other.
Just a pure and simple
friendship between girl and boy.
- Yeah, friendship.
It's an interesting question.
My short answer is, yes I do.
But I'm thinking of
lesbians that I interviewed,
who told me that they found,
sometimes found it simpler,
one woman I'm thinking
who I interviewed said, she found that her
closest friends were
straight women and gay men.
Because there was no confusion about
what kind of friendship
it was going to be.
And that in her group, if a woman somehow
developed a crush on someone
that wasn't returned,
it was sort of difficult for everybody.
For the whole group.
I'm thinking of women who told me that
gay men are their closest friends.
That's part of what
they told me about that.
It was wonderful.
They really loved the guy's company,
but they don't have to
worry about that tension.
So it think that layer is there.
But yeah, I have encountered examples of
if you want it, simple friendship.
If simple means no sexual overtones.
I do think it's possible.
- Thank you.
- Good luck.
(audience laughing)
- [Woman In Red Shirt] Hi,
I'm wondering if you have
any suggestions about how to, as a woman,
negotiate aspiration,
versus keeping your friends?
- Aspiration versus--
- versus keeping your friends.
You talked earlier about women,
like the girls who kicked their friend out
for being in the spelling bee.
Any tips for diffusing that?
- Yeah, it's so complicated.
I'm think again, real
anecdotes I heard about.
Women telling me that
they felt their friends
really stopped being their friends
because they got a
higher job, or whatever.
And sometimes it's just, if somebody has
something you really want,
it's hard to be with them.
So I'm thinking of a woman who told me,
she had a baby, and a friend of hers
who desperately wanted a baby,
and wasn't able to get pregnant,
just didn't wanna be with her
because it was so painful.
And then later they
reunited, and got past it.
So, what can you do about it?
I guess my solution to everything is,
you can try accommodating,
you can try talking about it.
And then sometimes you just have to
let it go for awhile, and see if you can
come back to it later.
Now you should know, I'm not a therapist,
and I have no experience
on which I'm basing this.
I'm just guessing.
Thank you.
- [Woman In Red And
White Shirt] Thank you.
I've been a big fan of
your writing for awhile.
- Thank you.
- So, in one of your books
you talked about sympathy.
And how men and women
perceive it very differently.
- Sympathy.
- Yeah, and how women,
when you, women friends,
when you express sympathy,
they see it as the sameness,
getting on the same level.
And you could say the exact
same thing to a male friend,
or a male partner, and they
view it as hierarchical.
That you're putting them down.
And I found that fascinating.
And I've noticed that a lot.
But I don't know how to navigate it.
So if you could elaborate on that at all,
that would be wonderful.
Thank you.
- Yeah, I agree.
It's fascinating.
You know who helped me understand that?
Robert Bly.
Do you remember, around
the time that my book,
You Just Don't Understand
was a Bestseller,
Robert Bly has a book called Iron John,
that was also best-selling.
And we did a thing together.
And he really helped me to understand.
I never quite understood this myself.
He said that sympathy seems to be,
like you said, a put down.
And also a reminder of this bad thing
that you wanna forget.
So, he was saying for many men,
the kindest thing you can do is
act as if it didn't happen.
(laughing)
Help them forget it.
Yeah, it's so widespread.
And I have encountered
really serious issues
among people who are close.
One couple how had been
through 9/11 together.
They had an apartment quite close
to the World Trade Center.
And so they had been
very traumatic for them.
And the wife wanted to talk about it,
and the husband didn't.
And the more she wanted to
talk about it and he wouldn't,
the more alienated she felt,
the more alone she felt,
the more let down she felt.
And the more she kept
trying to talk about,
when what he really wanted
to do was not talk about it,
and move on, was upsetting to him.
So I guess I'm gonna sound
like a broken record,
but it think if they had talked about it,
and kind of come to an
understanding of why
each of them is reacting
this different way,
then maybe they could
figure out a compromise.
And that's what, you
know, what I'm called by
journalists about all
these things I write about,
they always wanna know tips.
What can you do?
What's the tip?
And I always say, I
can't give tips because
each situation is different.
Each person is different.
The tip I give is understanding.
If you both understand what's going on,
then you can decide how to proceed.
And so you might decide,
I might just have to
not offer sympathy.
It makes me feel bad, because I think
I'm letting him down, or I
should be offering sympathy.
But I realize that's what he wants.
So I'm giving him the
gift of what he wants.
And he might have to learn
to offer some sympathy.
Because that's what
might be helpful to you.
So I don't know if that's hugely helpful,
but that's my thoughts.
Hi.
- [Woman In Red Shirt]
First I wanna say thank you
very much for your
research and your writing.
I used your research on
gender differences in
communication when I was
teaching at the college level,
and now the teacher has
become student again.
And so my questions is pertaining to,
if you're doing any research,
or the research of your colleagues on
intergenerational differences
in terms of friendship.
I'm in my early 50s.
I have, I'm probably,
I'm near the top end.
I'm at one of the seminaries
here through the GTU.
And a lot of my colleagues
are in their 20s and 30s.
They're the age of my adult children.
They're the age, a little bit older than
the age of the students I used to teach.
And just a general trend is
circumspect...
Reticent.
And I can do the whole texting,
and the social media thing.
But I have a sibling that's
only two and a half years
younger than myself, and her primary mode
of communication is through texting.
Some of this may be addressed
in your talk tomorrow,
but is conversation, is
intimacy through conversation
becoming a lost art,
as those of us that are
in the boomer generation, and
maybe some of the Gen-Xers
continue to age and fade out?
- Yeah.
I will have a bit to say,
a lot to say tomorrow
about generational differences
and use of social media.
But especially the mechanics of it.
And assumptions about what's
appropriate and what's not.
And use of punctuation, and
other markers like that.
But the question of
friendships across age,
I have a bit to say about it in the book,
but not a whole lot.
And sometimes what people
told me in those interviews
about friendships with older or younger,
much older or much younger friends,
often ended up being about social media.
Like students saying that she really
considered this older
friend a good friend,
but that friend didn't understand that
having a Facebook page open didn't mean
she was actually open for interaction.
She might be in class with
the Facebook page open.
Not in my class.
I don't allow it.
But yeah, no I'm sure there's
more to say about that
in maybe a future book.
Thank you.
- [Woman In White Shirt]
Since it's welcome back
to Berkeley, I wanna ask
a political question.
So we're reading, we're
hearing from many people
we have to learn to talk with people
and listen to people
with whom we don't agree.
And I think it's one more layer about
what are your values,
in addition to all these
things you say about rituals and styles.
So it feels impossible.
I don't think I want tips, but maybe,
maybe I do want tips.
But do you have any
insight that could help us?
- I'm asked about that a lot.
I wrote a book called
The Argument Culture.
It was published in 1998,
but I think it's more
true, and more accurate
and relevant today than
it was even back then.
And the point I made there is that our
public discourse is polarizing,
because we turn everything into a fight.
And the news media,
and politics certainly,
they exaggerate that.
They don't find people to put on who are
somewhere in the middle.
They find the most extreme
sides that they can find,
even if they have to scour the fringes
of lunacy to find them.
And they won't even cover
something if there isn't
another side, and they make
everything into two sides,
where most things are not two sides.
There are many sides.
And I think what we're reaping now,
is the harvest of that being a norm
in our public discourse over so long.
And it has crept into
personal relationships.
I think people are more confrontational,
more belligerent in
private attraction now,
because of that tone being so pervasive
in our public discourse.
And I think it's corrosive.
Corrosive to the human spirit.
The specific question.
Everyone's telling us now
you have to talk to people
that you don't agree with,
and how do we do that?
I've certainly encountered the phenomemon
that people are less likely to do it now.
People who won't go home
to their relatives because,
okay, they knew that their
relatives were Republican.
That was okay, they put it aside.
But now, knowing somebody voted for Trump
they feel is so, that
ramifications have been
so terrible that they just
don't wanna deal with it.
Okay, I'll say one thing.
I have read that if you talk to people you
don't agree with, our
impulse it to tell them
what we think, and change their minds.
And nobody changes their mind because
of something you told them.
But if you listen to them,
and have them tell you
everything that they think,
and you really listen, and
you really consider it,
that if you then eventually
work your way around
to showing another perspective,
they'd be more likely to hear it.
So, maybe that's one little bit of advice.
I think we're done.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
(upbeat music)